[Music]
when I was a kid I was in eighth grade
and sister Teresa a teacher wants to
teach us the difference between boys and
girls
she picked two people to come up to the
front of clash ghosts Kevin and Donna
you come up to the front of class and
bring your books and so we both went up
to the front of class and stood there
with our books and then sister Teresa
goes okay just sit down and we were all
like what's matter and she's like well
the difference between boys and girls or
girls hold their books like this boys
hold their books like this but Kevin
held it like this that was a moment I
was like I'm a right dog how dare you
nod buddy coming at you woman
yeah I've been steeped in the world of
comic books
I don't read anything currently anymore
but this is kind of where I'm most at
home in a comic book store whenever I go
into one cuz we travel a lot like with
Jay and Silent Bob we'll be traveling
across the country with the reboot
Roadshow tour every city we go to will
go into the comic book store but I tend
to go old stuff like when I came in
immediately I looked at the rack and I'm
like oh my god they're getting 25 bucks
for definitely 45 now looking at books
that are law books at this point classic
wall books yeah but books that I
actually bought off the spinner rack
back in the day that's incredible like
when I look at that and I'm like oh Lord
I had that like the Batman year to that
cover you know oh and that's the
predecessor to what became mask of the
phantasm and stuff I bought that book
off the rack I remember having that
preacher off the rack like it's crazy
of course the Dark Knight Returns and
now you see them up on the wall as
classic books and they're like I'm old
for heaven's sake
eight films eight US films have ever won
a golden lion and I'll accompany one of
them is the Joker's I was delighted look
at any great comic book movie is a win
for everybody right that's what we want
we love these characters we just want to
see him taken seriously and I remember
when they announced this movie I was
like best yeah that would be great and a
bunch of people were like crapping on
I'm like no no man like this is DC
Warner Brothers finding their footing
after like spending a few years trying
to be Marvel now they're like you know
what we're just we're filmmaker friendly
company we give filmmakers things they
run with them we're not gonna try to
interconnect them we just can't go back
to doing what we do best yeah and
because of that you got like a really
wonderful Wonder Woman movie really
wonderful Aquaman moving now it sounds
like an amazing job movie I know and how
touching and wonderful was it so they
found their footing and if it means that
we don't get them all interconnected
it's fine I'll take a Golden Lion over
and we'll get the references elsewhere
then we get a true walking finished joke
and think about it right yeah I mean 19
20 or 21
when Killing Joke came out and you know
you read Killing Joke for the first time
you're like finding your religion and
suddenly you're like oh my lord like
this characters like badass do they
could you imagine if they did this and
you know in the movies we've had
versions of the Joker which have been
fun every incarnation of the Joker we've
appreciated on some level or another
even Jared Leto but this one just seems
like the promise of Killing Joke come to
life yeah and Todd's not even a comic
book guy right you know I'm sorry
separating it which is what I think in
else world should be sometimes you need
to put this in the hands of somebody
who's just like I'm a storyteller yeah I
don't go deep in this material I haven't
read all the interconnected but I think
this sounds like a good idea is he's
gonna win it's gonna win enough yeah
it's happening we're fine and I love
that Heath got it and now like the Joker
is the character to the part people are
like oh it's readily credible it's here
think about it it's like playing the
modern-day Lucifer said yeah it's evil
and carnate with charm and style panache
it's very Shakespearean so you could
take that character in a number of
directions
and you talked about not making it into
you film but I feel like I don't know if
this is my my USQ bias the shared
universe you built is a lot of
characters referencing themselves
playing other characters their Star Wars
references people lose hands there's a
lot of MCU when you watch those films is
there a better you that's like I built
this pop culture Canon and I love that
the MCS made this whenever I watch those
movies like usually someone online is
like hey you had a movie universe first
and I was like well technically I stole
her from Marvel like they just didn't
have movies yet but like in the comics
everybody knew each other and I love
that you know for me it was a John
Hughes thing John he was like back
doored all of his movies together yeah
where he wasn't really prominent and
they never did big crossover anything
like that but they were all kind of set
in Shermer Illinois and this like
suburban Chicago area and as a kid who
just liked movies I like that like it
was he didn't go out of his way it
wasn't like you know collect them all
but it was a little bit extra something
for you if you went to all those movies
you're like Shermer Illinois they said
that that's where the kids went to
detention in breakfast law stuff like
that they did that in those movies and
and I brought it into my movies because
them also because of comics cuz DC
Marvel also a little bit because it
coming to America remember in coming to
America at one point Eddie Murphy's like
walking through the park and gives money
to some bums and then all sudden you
find out the bums are Don Ameche and
Ralph Bellamy traded places I remember
being in the movie theater that night be
like oh my god you just know you felt
like the smartest person in the world
they know does everybody understand what
has happened here you know and now we
live in that culture where movies are
based on that market it on that and
stuff like that so it's a heady time but
I'm not responsible for I was just one
guy who was like let me connect all the
movies like John
you